let us now take stock and summarize what
we have done for these two processes the
Bernoulli and the Poisson process and
their relation the Poisson process runs
in continuous time who are as for the
Bernoulli process time is discrete and
is divided into slots the Poisson
process is defined by a single parameter
lambda which is the intensity or arrival
rate and tells us the expected number of
arrivals per unit time for the Bernoulli
process we have again one basic
parameter which is the probability of
success at any given trial or the
probability of an arrival during each
one of the slots based on our model we
were interested in three kinds of
quantities and we found the
distributions of them the first quantity
is the number of arrivals during a
certain time interval for the discrete
case the number of arrivals has a
binomial distribution whereas for the
Poisson case the distribution is that of
a Poisson random variable then we looked
at the time until the first arrival or
the time between consecutive arrivals
for the Bernoulli process that
distribution is geometric for the
Poisson process that distribution is
exponential note that in this instance
were dealing with a discrete random
variable but here with a continuous
random variable and then as a
generalization we could find the time
until the case arrival which in the
present case is given by an Erlang
distribution and for the Bernoulli case
we developed one particular formula and
that formula is actually known under the
name of a Pascal distribution all of
these results for the Poisson case were
obtained because we used an
approximation argument that is we had
the results for the Bernoulli case but
then we argued that the Poisson process
is a limiting case of the Bernoulli
process in which we take time divided
into a large number of slots during each
one of the slots however we have a small
probability of an arrival and this is
done in a way so that the product of
these two numbers
stays a constant by using a finer and
finer discretization
we could approach the Poisson process
arbitrarily close by a Bernoulli process
and then we used the Bernoulli formulas
in which we took the limit as Delta was
going to zero and this gave us the
result for the Poisson case